[Music]  henderson elementary school students  getting ready to roll up their sleeves  get their hands on experience in the  garden because four schools in that city  have been awarded the state's only farm  to school grant  the 88 thousand dollar grant will help  fund and create some of these hydroponic  gardening systems at  robert taylor gordon mccaw faye galloway  and j  marlin walker elementary schools  students will get hands-on physical  science learning learn how to operate a  student-run farmer's market as well  the program starts this school year and  then it also provides free and reduced  price meals to children that are  eligible